ici qu'est l'islet et je me trouve
devant la maison du professeur i lay my
awesome qui vient de recevoir le prix
nobel de chimie
il a et mike goodson des pièces est
clair le nobel n'est pas un concours de
popularité cca autrement vous pourriez
avoir une chance de gagner savons
renommée s'il avoue a pu douter de mon
intellect si supérieur de façon formelle
qu'ils me behr est boudée vous et les
examens dans deux semaines si j'ai pas à
jeun faudrait tout le monde de ma
relation scandaleuse avec toi pourquoi
donner à ton âme entendait alors tu lis
à droite père affectueux i lay my aussi
nobel désigné par tu écoute bien ok j'ai
été pris en otage par un homme brutal
oh merde quel genre de père très de son
propre fils comme ça tu sais ça me
semble la bonne façon de venger la
mémoire de divers je vais t'aider à
réussir
monsieur vous devriez venir ici tu a
renvoyé le pouce d'un homme tu crois
qu'on aurait retenu toute leur attention
avec une photo de toi et du journal le
cri kidnapping partenaires alors je
t'explique le plan pendant ton père se
demande si la vie est mieux sans toi la
police des personnes hélas se
précipitent car la mauvaise mais c'est
bizarre les gars on a fait une petite
erreur
la rançon une revanche pendant ce temps
aux mailles
une fois le dépôt fait on peut s'amuser
monsieur là la cooper 120 croyable
si vous ne pouvez lui faire honneur
essayant ses autres je suis sûr qu'ils
allaient faire un tour la librairie pour
voir une fille on sera mieux chez moi tu
dois mettre le basque cinglé quoi cinglé
c'est qu'un choix parquet il ne reste
qu'une solution d'abord vous perdez mon
argent qui doit nous conduire à barclays
ensuite pas un mot de barclays au fait
le payer un million de dollars je
comptais pas la sortie nord ouest qui
est il si on voit personne dedans mais
aucun bruit de lui je n'ai pas entendu
l'entrée
ils croiront pas que tu as fait un
kidnapping tu vois ce que tu fais le
prix de la rançon d'où vient la voiture
même endroit que la dernière l'église tu
la voulais tu parles comme si c'était un
crime
tu viens